well apparently it's not enough for the
tech companies to know what you do and
they do know what you do increasingly
they want to control what you do and
what you see and what you think
during a recent meeting with investors
Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg revealed
that his company has been ranking news
outlets by how trustworthy they are with
less trusted outlets being penalized on
Facebook's newsfeed trusted by the way
by Facebook not by you but by Mark
Zuckerberg and his deputies meanwhile
Twitter is implementing a system to
suppress tweets it regards as harassment
even if those tweets actually break no
rules in other words if Twitter
disagrees with the political orientation
of the tweets Brett Larson hosts fox
news headlines 24/7 investigates big
tech for this show are grateful he does
he joins us tonight hey good to be here
we have been investigating this story
over the past few days now involving
Facebook changes to how they handle news
sources in users news feed as you
mentioned in a meeting with media
company executives from the New York
Times to news corp which is the parent
company of Fox News Facebook CEO Mark
Zuckerberg said they will be relying on
user surveys to determine which news
sources are quote broadly trusted the
comments were made following Facebook's
f8 Developer Conference that was at the
beginning of the month and this is one
of the many changes the social media
giant has made in an effort to combat
fake news fake accounts and BOTS that
help amplify and spread fake information
now I spoke with Facebook earlier today
and they assured me that this isn't an
effort to censor any ideas or beliefs
and that the random sampling of
trustworthiness happens frequently to
ensure sites are getting a fair shake it
works like this a user will be presented
with a simple yes-or-no question about a
new site are you familiar with this site
a yes answer brings up the next question
to rate it for trustworthiness on a
scale of one to five now what about fake
accounts boosting the trustworthiness of
a not so trustworthy news outlet well
Facebook just this year has removed more
than half a billion fake accounts
further those headlines like they pulled
over to help this dog what happened next
will amaze you dot dot not going to get
the kind of ranking in your newsfeed
going forward as the changes are also
meant to crack down on so-called clique
and focus more on news especially local
news now as for paying providers for
that news no deal cable operators pay to
carry channels like Fox for their
customers but when asked if Facebook
will do the same thing the online
giant's saying they don't see a need for
that despite the fact that they're
renewing focus on local news it would
seem that kind of revenue would breathe
new life into local newspapers and news
outlets that are struggling to remain
relevant and profitable in the age of
digital and Tucker these changes aren't
helping us feel any better in this
effort to see more news from friends and
less news from media sites
it actually puts us in a bad mood
because we compare ourselves to our
friends and our peers and we see what
we're missing out on think parties and
awesome vacations that were not on
Tucker and that's what we all want we
want to feel bad maybe we need a
vacation from social I think we all do I
think we do right great to see you
thanks Tucker good to be here